at nearly 25 points a game there's a lot
and look at the structural integrity and
both got thumbs up birds today in the
rest suddenly and they got the job done
it was gonna be boom or bust for them
this season but let me ask you guys a
quick question who's got the better duo
that's a great question he Los Angeles
yeah Clippers and Lakers look at it
sooner or later long over the Windler
rookie steps in that's black 5 fall
welcome John Elmore out of Marshall
handling the ball now
streets with another three-point
opportunity and that's off the court
then
[Applause]
doesn't take much to jam that home when
you're seven six here this afternoon
there's no doubt about a taco fall
standing and delivery it's Boston by 13
this kid is stealing I'm gonna be like
the way he's past shoot it and it's over
all nod to know how to play green up top
to fall taco Falls a lot better
basketball player welcome to give him
credit no more to clean it inside the
policy how is in the post octo fall that
he allowed but I throw them to the
basket there you go there you go
Rosie Kowski could only stand there and
wait for the applause the two-time SEC
Player of the Year Brad Williams that
comes up short back out to Tremont
waters there's a lot de faire I ran out
of syllables last night I'm sorry
appreciate it
with the punch a long way to go but look
if you loose down and you put it in a
place where only he could catch it so in
the last two possessions actions I mean
there's one guy in the building what's
gonna be able to get that seven-foot
same stretching out to make the catch at
that time he doesn't pull it down taco
in general though like I talked to guys
here and they think I mentioned in the
report earlier but they think he's you
know a G League type player and let's
see where he goes from there how do you
feel about an Ellen of Marant and Jaron
Johnson two halves highest Jones there
and the thing about Moran is he can play
with taco fall let's see yeah money huh
Corey Brewer and green work out the last
time they ever worked out at the
University of Florida Billy Donovan
invited me down a lot by fall his third
of the game ball is not coming out the
bolo ended up hitting it takes down the
rim
bachchi tips at first you'll feel much
more comfortable in ten minutes right
Rock number four for taco fall it would
be a blast
tako fall over the alley you know a nice
screen it's really good past running at
his size he's running again run to the
floor well steps is a tank for taco
falling on the floor man look at him get
out that's pretty good
come on give us another stab we got a
lot of money tied up in stat guys over
eight points five rebounds four block
you know Knick fans we're yeah well they
invented basketball blah blah blah blah
blah double figures I like how it was it
was a ton of course sense you know
people said well you're not a point
guard what position do you play well
look at time what's up you guys this
Taylor Brooks with bleacher report make
sure that you subscribe for some more
video content